Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Neun Spieltage sind in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer schon absolviert. Und wir wollen mal wieder genauer draufblicken, diesen Spieltag Revue passieren lassen und uns ein bisschen Zeit nehmen für Hannover 96 und den FCK. Hallo und herzlich willkommen in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nr. 229. Wie ihr gehört habt, wollen wir sprechen über die 2. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und freue mich, mich hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Zwei wunderbare Podcast-Stimmen, also allein akustisch wird das ein Gedicht. Ich begrüße hier Tobias Rieger, der Ed Runner Tobi. Ihr kennt ihn vielleicht von der MSP-WG auf meinsportpodcast.de. Hallo Tobi, schön, dass du mal wirklich hier bist.
Hallo aus Hannover. Vielen Dank für die Einladung, Max.
Ja, das wird total ungewohnt, dass wir mal eine Sendung miteinander machen, wo wir kein Martin-Kind-Trinkspiel draus machen müssen, weil wir irgendwie dreißigmal diesen Arm fallen lassen.
Ich habe auch keinen Tab geöffnet mit irgendwelchen aufgeführten Strukturen, KGH, GmbH. Es ist mir heute alles egal. Wenn du dazu irgendwas fragst, ich werde es verweigern, glaube ich.
Ja, ah, nee, da habe ich auch gar keinen Bock drauf. Das stimmt, tatsächlich hatte ich in allen letzten Aufnahmen mit dir auch immer so dieses Schaubild, das man da im Internet findet, mit den ganzen Co-Kagesen. Ach, schön, dass wir heute mal über Sportliches reden dürfen. Also wir werden auf Hannover 96 einen Schwerpunkt legen und den zweiten, den legen wir auf den 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Und da begrüße ich Sebastian Zobel vom SWA und vom Nur der FCK Podcast. Bei Twitter ist er der, add Twitter redo, mit drei O's. Hallo Sebastian.
Hi Max, auch dir noch mal vielen Dank für die Einladung. Und ich bin sehr, sehr froh, dass wir heute auch im Bezug auf den 1. FC Kaiserslautern nicht über irgendwelche Gesellschaften sprechen müssen oder Planinsolvenzen oder sonst was. Ich freue mich auf Sportliche.
Aber wirklich, wir müssen auch mit dir nicht darüber reden, ey, wo ist die Kohle schon wieder hin? Was ist das für ein Luxemburger, der da irgendwie einsteigen möchte? Es ist schön, euch zwei –ich sage es jetzt einfach mal –Problemkinder des Rasenfunks mal einfach zu sportlichen Dingen hier zu haben. Und es liegt aber nicht an euch, dass ihr Problemkinder seid. Das möchte ich ausdrücklich betonen. Also, wir wollen in die 2. Liga der Männer springen und wir gehen diesmal mal die Partien durch, machen das ein bisschen anders als zuletzt im 2. Liga Kurzpass. Wir beginnen bei der Tabelle ganz hinten und da grüßt der 1. FC Magdeburg von Tabellenplatz 18. Sieben Punkte erst nach neun Spieltagen. Und auch an diesem Spieltag kamen keine Punkte mit dazu, denn beim Aufeinandertreffen mit Jens Härtel von Hansa Rostock gibt es eine Niederlage. Insgesamt endet dieses Spiel mit 1 zu 3. Tobi, was hat man denn verpasst, wenn man dieses Spiel nicht gesehen hat?
Man hat gar nicht so schlecht den Magdeburger verpasst, hatte ich das Gefühl. 1 zu 3 und den Anschlusstreffer auch erst in der 94. erzielt, klingt aus Magdeburger Sicht alles sehr, sehr unglücklich und sehr, sehr unschön. Ich fand aber, dass die deutlich mehr vom Spiel hatten, als es im ersten Moment so ein bisschen scheint. Sie hatten große Chancen. Ich glaube, Schula war es der zwei dicke Chancen, die Führung ranzuholen. Hat ein bisschen Pech, Rostock auf der anderen Seite ein bisschen Glück. Und am Ende stehen Rostocker da, die das ziemlich abgezockt zu Hause gemacht haben, mit weniger Spielanteilen, locker die Tore gemacht, Tröger mit dem Doppelpack, einmal schön und einmal sehr schön. Das erste war schön, das zweite war sehr schön. Von der rechten Seite ins linke lange Ecke bolzt. Das war insgesamt nicht das, wonach es auf dem ersten Blick aussieht, würde ich sagen.
Sebastian, wie haben dir bei den Teams gefallen?
Da kann ich eigentlich nur das unterstreichen, was Tobi gerade gesagt hat. Das können wir ab jetzt einfach bei allen Spielen so machen. Tobi sagt, was er denkt. Und ich setze einfach nur einen Haken dran. Nein, das habe ich ganz genau so gesehen. Die Magdeburger haben eigentlich echt kein schlechtes Spiel gemacht. Aber ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Fluch in dieser Saison. Letztes Jahr war das die Übermannschaft in der dritten Liga. Ich habe das ja live miterlebt mit dem FCK. Da ist es fast schon tragisch, wie schlecht das in der zweiten Liga läuft. Ich glaube, ein Personal hier ist natürlich auch nicht unentscheidend. Du hast halt mit Baris Atik, der jetzt auch getroffen hat zum 3-1, noch jemanden gehabt, der diese Saison lange ausgefallen ist und letztes Jahr wirklich der Ausnahmespieler in der dritten Liga war. Von daher können die Jungs in Magdeburg schon kicken, aber irgendwie kriegen sie es bisher noch nicht in der Tabelle auf die Straße.
Sie kriegen einfach auch zu viele Gegentore. Also 22 Gegentore mit Abstand, die meisten in der Liga. Neun nach Standards. Als Hannoveraner fühle ich mich da immer direkt angesprochen, dass das irgendwie ein Problemfeld ist, diese Standards bei uns in letzter Zeit, oder früher eigentlich mehr offensiv als defensiv, aber bei Magdeburg auf jeden Fall defensiv. Und ja, so ist das dann halt Aufsteiger. Wenn du dann nicht so richtig den Schwung vielleicht vom Aufstieg mitnutzen kannst, schlecht in die Saison kommst, dann stehst du noch neun Spieltage auf dem letzten Platz. Und ich will jetzt nicht sagen, wie die Saison zu Ende geht, aber das sind zumindest nicht die besten Voraussetzungen, wenn du vom Kader her qualitativ nicht oben mitspielst, wenn du keinen Schwung mehr hast und dann so in die Saison startest. Das sieht alles nicht so ganz glücklich aus im Moment, was in Magdeburg passiert. Wir haben ja auch zu Hause gegen uns 4 zu 0 verloren, da fand ich sie katastrophal schlecht, also da hatten wir die komplett im Griff. Jetzt in Rostock war es ein bisschen anders, aber dann kommt halt auch kein Glück dazu.
Ja, also in der Tat Magdeburg das anfälligste Team nach Eckbällen, Hansa wiederum das gefährlichste Team nach Eckbällen, also dass das 3 zu 0 von Pröger dann genauso gefallen ist, war dann Folge, richtig? Und so barresartig muss man vielleicht noch sagen, der hat einen Strafstoß noch verschossen. Drei der letzten fünf konnte er nicht im Tor unterbringen, also der letzten fünf Strafstöße natürlich. Macht dann zwar immerhin den 1 zu 3 Treffer, eher ein Treffer in der Nachspielzeit, aber das ist ein Problem. Magdeburg lässt nämlich auch die meisten Schüsse aufs eigene Tor zu. Und das, obwohl man ja einen sehr beibesitzorientierten Stil hat, der nicht so ganz funktioniert. Ist die Mannschaft mit dem meisten Beibesitz in der Liga, 61 Prozent vor St. Pauli und dem Hamburger SV, nicht so ganz überraschend, wenn man so wie du, Sebastian, sie schon in der dritten Liga verfolgt hat, also die Spielweise, aber vielleicht die Ergebnisse, die rauskommen, dann ein bisschen. Und auf der anderen Seite, Hansa Rostock, die sind richtig, richtig gut gestartet. Vier Siege, keine Unentschieden, fünf Niederlagen, also bisher Hopp oder Top bei Hansa, aber solange so viel Hopp mit dabei ist, passt das ja, Sebastian, oder?
Ja, absolut. Ich würde sagen, das ist durchaus solide. Kann man auf jeden Fall sich auch gut anschauen, was die da spielen. Und von daher bin ich mal gespannt. Ja, ich habe Rostock eigentlich immer auch so ein bisschen auf dem Zettel, aber das ist auch noch so ein bisschen von früher, glaube ich. Rostock war für mich eigentlich immer eine gute Zweitligamannschaft oder teilweise ja auch mehr. Und von daher bin ich echt mal gespannt, wie das da so weitergeht.
Sind auf jeden Fall sehr effizient. Mit neun Toren muss man erst mal zwölf Punkte herausschießen. Das läuft alles sehr gut. Und gut lief es auch. Endlich mal, möchte man fast sagen. Für die Spielvereinigung Kräuter-Viert der erste Sieg. Er wurde geschafft und das ausgerechnet gegen den SC Paderborn. Am Ende ist es ein 2 zu 1, was wir da haben. Auch wenn du es dir gewünscht hast, dass jetzt immer Tobi vorlegt und du nur sagst, du siehst genau so, so können wir es nicht machen. Du musst jetzt vorlegen. Wie haben dir die beiden Teams gefallen?
Ja, also ich muss erst mal sagen, Fürth, das war auch lange Zeit irgendwie tragisch. Da habe ich mir auch deutlich mehr erwartet diese Saison, muss ich sagen. Und da, man muss schon sagen, ich glaube aus Sicht der Fürther, endlich hat es mal geklappt mit dem Dreier. Ja, das war schon eine gute Leistung, wenn auch die Fürther deutlich früher eigentlich schon in Führung gehen müssen und Abiyamada das Ding noch mal eigentlich nur frei einschieben muss und dann an die Latte knallt. Und ich sag mal beim 1-0 durch Michalski, da sieht die Abwehr der Paderborner auch nicht besonders gut aus, dass es irgendwie so ein Ball, der ewig lange in der Luft ist. Und dann, ja, das darf eigentlich nicht fallen. Von daher, ja, es kommt auch noch mal dazu, dass Paderborn, die wirklich eine sehr, sehr starke Saison bislang spielen, dass die ein gutes Spiel gemacht haben, aber kein so ganz so gutes wie sonst, auch ein bisschen unglücklich waren. Das 1 zu 1 haben sie super rausgespielt. Also das ist wirklich herausragend kombiniert. Muss ich echt sagen, es hat mir sehr, sehr gut gefallen, das 1-1 durch Sribini. Und ja, da haben sie gezeigt, was sie eigentlich für eine Qualität haben, die Paderborner. Und dann beim 2-1 hatten die Viertel auch nochmal echt Glück. Da war der Ball nochmal abgefälscht von Gregota. Und ja, vielleicht haben sie sich jetzt auch einfach mal verdient ihren ersten Sieg, aber dass das dann gegen Paderbornen, gegen so ein Spitzen-Team ist, ist ja am Ende dann durchaus auch glücklich.
Hat es vielleicht auch Tobi ein bisschen mit der Verletzung von Felix Platte zu tun? Muss man die noch mit einbeziehen, wenn man auf dieses Spiel guckt? Musste schon nach 29 Minuten raus?
Also Felix Platte, ich glaube, sechs Tore, vier Assists, Top-Score der 2. Liga, ist für Paderbornen einfach super, super wichtig. Hat, glaube ich, einen ganz, ganz großen Anteil daran gehabt, was da am Anfang der Saison mit Paderbornen passiert ist. Der hat, glaube ich, die ersten fünf Spiele jedes Spiel getroffen und dann nach 30 Minuten runter. Ich habe vorhin noch mal versucht, rauszufinden, ob es schon was Neues gibt, aber es ist jetzt noch irgendwie keine Diagnose. Ich glaube, er selber lässt sich zitieren mit, geht bald wieder, hoffentlich. Mal schauen, wie das dann in zwei Wochen, wenn die Länderspielpause zu Ende ist, wirklich aussieht. Aber ja, das war natürlich –ich meine, wir brauchen jetzt nicht groß drum rum reden –das war die größte Überraschung des Spieltags. Der Erste verliert beim Letzten. Das habe ich persönlich nicht kommen sehen. Ich fand es natürlich umso schöner, seitdem ich da oben auch öfter mal wieder auf die Tabelle gucke. Das schadet sicherlich nicht, wenn Paderborn auch mal wieder ein Spiel verliert. Und ich weiß nicht, die Vierter, so schlecht konnten sie ja eigentlich auch nicht sein, wie sie in der Tabelle standen. Also Absteiger, ja, Bielefeld hat es auch schwer gehabt dieses Jahr, gar keine Frage. Sie sind auch schwer reingekommen. Aber Fürth hat jetzt gut den Trainer abgegeben, der ist zu uns gekommen. Die haben ein, zwei, wahrscheinlich relativ wichtige Offensivspieler auch abgegeben. Aber insgesamt habe ich nicht damit gerechnet, dass die so katastrophal ins Jahr starten. Jetzt haben sie vielleicht so ein bisschen mit diesem Spiel –und der Trainer stand ja glaube ich auch sehr unter Druck, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe –hieß es Siegen oder Fliegen für Mark Schneider. Von daher, hu, vielleicht haben sie jetzt die Kurve gekriegt, können den Schwung mit in die Länderspielpause nehmen und finden dann zurück in die Saison.
Ja, wir werden es beobachten. Es geht jetzt weiter gegen Sandhausen, vielleicht nicht der dankbarste Gegner für die Spielvereinigung. Ich bin mir da noch nicht so ganz sicher, ob man dem trauen kann, denn da musste schon auch einiges zusammenkommen. Und aus der anderen Perspektive gesehen war Paderborn in dem Spiel auch einfach nicht so stark wie bisher. Der SCP hat mir bisher sehr gut gefallen mit Lukas Kwasniok und einer sehr Paderborn-artigen Spielweise.
Was ist denn eine Paderborn-artige Spielweise, Max?
Vorne halt voll drauf, Tor, Tor, Tor, hinten, ach ja, wir kassieren auch immer mal wieder eins. Also ist jetzt gar nicht so schlecht bisher in dieser Saison gewesen, aber ich finde, dass sie schon eben sehr vertikal spielen. Du siehst ständig, mehrere Spieler einfach in vollem Tempo aufs gegnerische Tor zu laufen. So ist für mich eine Paderborn-artige Spielweise.
Und das können die halt auch echt ganz gut. Also Sebastian hat es gerade erwähnt, die können dazu auch noch gut Fußball spielen. Das 1-1, was Muslia einleitet, das war einfach Zucker pur. Also wer lässt den Ball da durch? So was siehst du in der zweiten Liga, wenn es gut läuft, einmal am Wochenende, aber eigentlich eher einmal im Monat, dass jemand so mitdämmt, den Ball ist. Es war wirklich schön. Und die stehen nicht ohne Grund da oben. Wir haben auch in Paderborn ordentlich auf den Ballon gekriegt mit 4 zu 2. Das war kein schöner Ausflug. Die sind auch, glaube ich, insgesamt nicht ganz überraschend da oben. Du hast es gerade gesagt, Paderborn, Liga Fußball, das ist halt auch Zweitliga Fußball, kann das auch sein. Die wissen, was ihnen passiert, die wissen, was sie annehmen müssen. Ich finde das schon relativ beeindruckend, was die da diese Saison leisten.
Ich finde ja, Paderborn ist so eine Mannschaft, die nehmen viele so langsam erst so richtig ernst, weil das war immer so eine Mannschaft, die bei vielen total unterm Radar geflogen ist. Wer ist Paderborn? Was machen die da? Spielen die da wirklich Fußball? Und mittlerweile zeigen die echt, dass die klar irgendwo vielleicht auch eine Fahrschulmannschaft sind. Aber ich meine, der FCK wäre zum Beispiel auch ganz gerne eine Fahrschulmannschaft zwischen erster und zweiter Liga. Von daher, also das ist ja echt super solide, was da die letzten Jahre gemacht wurde. Das ist echt guter Fußball, der da in Paderborn gespielt wird. Aber teilweise, das merke ich auch so, wenn ich mich mit anderen unterhalte, Paderborn fliegt immer so ein bisschen unterm Radar von den meisten.
Also ich habe zwei Punkte zu Paderborn zu machen. Das erste ist, Paderborn darf nie als Fahrstuhlmannschaft bezeichnet werden. Die sind eine Paternoster-Mannschaft, weil die halten ja zwischendurch gar nicht an. Die fahren ja immer durch. Und das zweite ist, vielleicht kommt das ein bisschen von der Trainerposition her. Du hattest eben mit Steffen Bromgaard einen sehr präsenten Trainer. Und da war Paderborn auch in aller Munde und dann ist er weggewechselt und man konnte jetzt glaube ich nicht erwarten, dass es dann doch wieder erfolgreich weitergehen würde und vor allem auch mit einem ähnlichen Spielstil zu dem, was Bromgaard gemacht hat. Aber Kvasniork hat es halt geschafft und deswegen vielleicht kommt das eben daher, dass man einfach nicht damit rechnen konnte, dass Paderborn wieder Paderborn sein würde. Und jetzt sehen wir es aber in der Saison ja noch mehr als in der letzten, finde ich. Also bisher zumindest. Nun ja, also das war das Spiel zwischen Paderborn und der Spielvereinigung, die ja trotzdem bei sieben Punkten jetzt nicht allzu rosig dasteht. Wir sprechen aktuell noch über den Tabellensebzehnten. Und auf Tabellenplatz 16 liegt Eintracht Braunschweig und auch da wird mit Blick auf deren Spiel gegen den KSC deutlich, wie gut das war für die Vörter, diese Partie gegen Paderborn gewonnen zu haben. Denn auch Eintracht Braunschweig konnte gewinnen und zwar gegen den KSC mit 2 zu 1. Und Braunschweig, Tobi hat gerade eine richtig gute Phase.
Ja, die sie unter anderem gegen uns hatten, wo sie ein 1 zu 1 im Derby. Ich glaube, so ganz zufrieden waren die am Ende gar nicht damit und bei uns war man dann doch nicht so ganz unzufrieden mit dem Unentschieden. Davor hatten sie gegen Nürnberg gewonnen. Also sieben Punkte aus drei Spielen, die nehmen im Moment Fahrt auf. Das Spiel war, glaube ich, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, Freitagabend parallel zu 96 in Sandhausen. Das war auf jeden Fall das weniger unterhaltsame Spiel von den beiden, fand ich. Das hat jetzt keinen so richtig aus den Sitzen gerissen, aber Braunschweig hat das gar nicht schlecht gemacht. Das Tor von Uccia kurz vor der Halbzeit geht wahrscheinlich zu großem Teil auf die Kappe von Gersbeck, dem Torwart von Karlsruhe, der einfach ganz komisch, wenn man das noch mal in der Wiederholung sieht, im Tor steht, also viel zu weit links und da war halt einfach so viel Platz, der musste halt reingehen. Und dann gleich in die Karlsruhe noch aus nach der Pause. Ich fand, das war auch alles verdient und in Ordnung, dass sie das ausgeglichen haben. Aber so wirklich überzeugt hat Karlsruhe dann in der zweiten Hälfte nicht und Braunschweig macht das 2 zu 1 wieder durch Uca, der, glaube ich, jetzt angekommen ist in Braunschweig. Und ich so ungernig das auch sage, es war wohl doch ein ganz guter Transfer von den Braunschweigern, den zu holen. Also ich hatte vor der Saison oder bzw. der kam, glaube ich, erst zum dritten Spieltag, hatte ich mit ein, zwei Menschen von Eintracht Braunschweig, die da so fan-technisch interessiert sind, geredet und die haben gesagt, der passt überhaupt nicht zu uns. Der ist viel zu alt. Also ich glaube, der ist nach dem Torwart, nach Fezic der älteste Spieler im Kader. Wir wollen eigentlich ein junges Konzept haben, was Transfers angeht, Spieler entwickeln und so weiter. Aber ich glaube, das war der Stein, der dem Braunschweiger so ein bisschen fehlte. Denn jetzt haben sie einen, der trifft da vorne regelmäßig und könnte vielleicht die Lösung für viele, viele Probleme sein. Das Ganze zusammen mit Ferrailly, der ihm da zweimal aufgelegt hat. Ich sage es ungern, aber das sah gar nicht so schlecht aus. Es war ein verdieter Sieg gegen Karlsruhe.
Ja, das kann ich eigentlich auch nur wieder unterschreiben, was Tobi gerade gesagt hat. Aber um es in den Worten der Braunschweiger Fans zu sagen, weil ich glaube, das würde Tobi aus seiner Sicht ungern so machen, kann man eigentlich nur sagen, uccha, uccha, uccha. Also der ist ja wirklich angekommen da, der Junge. Ich glaube, vier Tore hat er schon gemacht jetzt. Letzte Saison war ja gar nichts los mit ihm bei Union. Und jetzt vor allem auch das zweite Tor, das ist, als ich mir das angeschaut habe, das war für mich so ein richtiges Mittelstürmer-Manier, wie er sich da durchsetzt und das Ding in der Mitte reinschweißt. Also das ist wirklich, das war für Braunschweig ein 1a-Transfer. Der Anthony, ich denke ja bei uccha auch immer noch an, ich weiß nicht, warum das so ist, aber daran, wie Holger Stanislavski damals noch als Köln-Trainer seinen Namen ausspricht, weil ich das immer total lustig fand, aber generell, ich habe ihn auch gerne reden gehört, den Stani damals. Aber was man ja auch sagen muss, das hätte ja auch, das war jetzt, glaube ich, kein Überspiel von Braunschweig, aber die hätten ja doch gut und gerne noch ein paar Tore mehr schießen können. Und der Gersberg im KSC-Kasten hat da doch auch nochmal einige echt gute Paraden gezeigt. Von daher steht zwar am Ende ein 2-1, was aber durchaus auch hätte ein 3 oder ein 4-1 sein können. Von daher, ja, ich sag mal, solide Leistung von Braunschweig.
Und damit hat Braunschweig 7 seiner 8 Punkte aus den letzten drei Spielen geholt, unter anderem, weil Uta jetzt schon im dritten Spiel nacheinander getroffen hat. Damit ist man aktuell auf Rang 8. Punktgleich mit unter anderem Sandhausen. Und über deren Spiel wollen wir jetzt sprechen. Das war nämlich das besagte Parallelspiel. Und jetzt sind wir auch bei einem Verein angekommen, über den wir ein bisschen länger reden wollen, nämlich bei Hannover 96. Für die Tobi Sandhausen ja so eine Art Angstgegner ist, beziehungsweise dass so eine Art, kann ich glaube ich sogar weglassen. Warum hat es denn dann diesmal geklappt?
Weil der Trainer nach, ich glaube vier Spielen waren es in Folge, mit der gleichen Startelf gesagt hat, wir müssen mal neue Impulse in die Mannschaft bringen und ein bisschen gewechselt hat. Er hatte zwei Spieler rausgekommen, jetzt muss ich ganz kurz überlegen, das waren, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, Leopold und Trizoldi, die relativ überraschend in die Startelf kamen vor vier Spielen und dann sich dort festgespielt haben und dafür hat er jetzt Schaub und Besuchskopf wieder reingebracht. Und ich glaube, das tat dem Ganzen gar nicht so schlecht. Am Ende, wenn du sagst, warum haben wir es dann doch gewonnen, dann gibt es natürlich viele Gründe, weil es ein sehr, sehr wildes Spiel war, weil der Schiedsrichter sehr, sehr wild war, weil der VAR sehr, sehr wild war und weil wir am Ende vielleicht einfach auch ein bisschen Glück hatten.
Das ist eine schöne Zusammenfassung. Also am Ende war es ein 3 zu 2. Es geht los mit 1 zu 0, dann gibt es einen Strafstoß, der so ewig gedauert hat, dass es entschieden wurde.
Der erste von potenziell 2.
Genau, dann ein Strafstoß und Gelb-Rot, was zurückgenommen worden wurde. Das war dann die zweite Szene, die du da angesprochen hast, vom Schiedsrichter Haselberger, der glaube ich erst sein drittes Zweitligaspiel gepfiffen hat. Also da wird er sich auch dran erinnern und vielleicht erklärt das auch, warum manches dann noch ein bisschen länger gedauert hat. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, müsste man näher einsteigen. Und dann zieht ja Hannover 96 davon und trotzdem wird es nochmal eng, weil eben dann Aydini nochmal die von Nielsen und Moroja herausgeschossene 3-1-Führung nochmal verkürzen kann. Ich habe jetzt von Hannover 96 immer nur so Bruchstücke gesehen in den letzten Wochen. Ist das typisch für Hannover, dass man Spiele nicht zumachen kann oder wie würdest du das einordnen?
Nee, das fände ich glaube ich ein bisschen hart. Wir haben mit einem Torabstand viele Spiele gewonnen. Aber ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, wir hatten dann unendlich viele Chancen, das auszubauen. Ein Blick auf die Tabelle zeigt mir, dass es im Moment ganz gut und teilweise auch ganz glücklich für uns läuft. Was vielleicht am Anfang der Saison noch nicht so gut war, was das Glück an ging, das späte Gegentor in Kaiserslautern, Sebastian wird sich erinnern. Dann am zweiten Spiel, das späteste Ausgleichstor von St. Pauli kassiert und da zwei Punkte liegen lassen. Das hat sich jetzt inzwischen zu –wir sind selbstbewusst genug –einen Eintore-Vorsprung auch über die Zeit zu spielen entwickelt, habe ich das Gefühl. Deckel drauf machen, ja vielleicht ist das einfach –was willst du bei 3-1, wenn du 3-1 führst, dann noch ein viertes und ein fünftes nachlegen, das wäre halt auch nicht Hannover 96. Also das würde mich arg irritieren. Wie gesagt, wir haben es in Magdeburg geschafft, haben 4-0 gewonnen, da haben wir aber von Anfang an das Spiel in der Hand gehabt. Magdeburg hat nicht wirklich groß Gegenwehr geleistet. Das war komplett unser Tag. Aber ansonsten spielen wir halt wie eine Mannschaft, die davon überzeugt ist, dass sie gut ist, dass sie das einigermaßen gut kann, was der Trainer von ihnen verlangt. Und dann bringen wir die Spieler halt so nach Hause. Das ist alles noch nicht zum Hochjubeln gedacht im Moment, aber es ist auf jeden Fall gut.
Und muss man da dann auch über Stefan Leitl, den Trainer, sprechen, wenn man eben die Frage stellt, was sich verändert hat bei Hannover 96? Oder kommen da verschiedene Faktoren zusammen? Spieler vielleicht auch, die eine gute Phase haben?
Ja, Spieler sicherlich auch, aber natürlich. Stefan Leitl ist da der Mann, über den wir sprechen müssen. Er hat die ersten, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, vier Spiele, hat dann noch mit einer Viererkette hinten gespielt und hat dann gemerkt, wohlgemerkt nach dem Sieg gegen Regensburg 1 zu 0, gab es eine relativ beachtenswerte Pressekonferenz. Er war stinksauer. Wir haben zu Hause 1 zu 0 gegen Regensburg gewonnen. Er war stinksauer. Auch zu Recht in meinen Augen hat die Mannschaft komplett angezählt, hat gesagt, was alles nicht gut war, Konzentration war nicht gut, wir haben uns aus dem Konzept bringen lassen von so einer Trinkpause. Danach lief gar nichts mehr zusammen. Und hat dann die eben angesprochenen Schaub und Bischofschke rausgenommen, um Trezoldi und Leopold zu bringen in die Mannschaft. Zwei junge Spieler, wenig Erfahrung, viel Hoffnung natürlich. Und die haben dann in dem neuen System mit der Dreierkette zusammen wirklich geglänzt. Und da haben wir das Spiel gegen Magdeburg gehabt, dann haben wir gegen Fürth 2-1 gewonnen, gegen Rostock 1-0 gewonnen, okay, gegen Braunschweig, da zählen sicherlich viele Faktoren rein in so einem Derby. 1-1, okay, das war eine gute Phase, da hat der Trainer was verändert, es hat funktioniert, die Spieler haben mitgezogen, die, die eingewechselt wurden, haben dann auch größtenteils mitgezogen, waren jetzt also nicht beleidigt, dass sie vielleicht nicht mehr von Anfang an gespielt haben und so jungen Spielern so ein bisschen den Rang abgelaufen gekriegt haben. Also das geht alles auf die Kappe vom Trainer, gar keine Frage. Da hat er viel gemacht, da hat er viel geschafft. Ich finde, er moderiert sehr, sehr gut. Er hat jetzt auch, wie gesagt, vor der Länderspielpause nochmal gesagt, wir müssen neue Impulse bringen, hat die beiden eben angesprochenen rausgenommen, hat Maxi Beier, den wir ausgeliehen haben in der zweiten Saison von Hoffenheim, hat den rausgenommen, der so ein bisschen so als heilige Figur hier im Moment gilt, weil es vielleicht der beste Fußballer im Kader ist. Aber auch das hat er vorangekündigt, es war keine Überraschung für irgendwen. Also ja, Stefan Leitl, der macht das sehr, sehr gut im Moment.
Sebastian, welchen Eindruck hast du von Hannover gewonnen? Es gab ja unter anderem dieses Aufeinandertreffen am ersten Spieltag auf dem Betzenberg. Das konnte der FCK noch mit 2 zu 1 gewinnen?
Ja, also Hannover 96 ist für mich natürlich eine Mannschaft, die auf jeden Fall zum Favoritenkreis zählt der Mannschaften, die um den Aufstieg mitspielen. Und allein schon nominell, was da im Kader am Start ist, das sind alles Spieler, die den Ball laufen lassen können. Das hat man am ersten Spieltag gegen uns, gegen den FCK auch schon gesehen. Wobei natürlich immer so eine Frage ist, wie aussagekräftig ein erster Spieltag ist. Aber ja, also die kommen jetzt langsam wieder dahin, wo ich sie eigentlich von Anfang an gesehen habe. Und ja, das ist einfach so, wenn du dann siehst, wie so Nielsen da hochsteigt und den Ball da reinköpft. Das ist einfach abgezockt. Und ja, ich rede jetzt ganz, ganz stark. Und dann schauen wir mal, wie das am Ende läuft, Tobi, ne?
Was ich über euch gleich noch sage, ja.
Aber beim Tobi hat sich schon alles zusammengezogen, als du gesagt hast, sie sind mit Favorit auf den Aufstieg verbutet.
Ja, absolut. Also da hat sich alles zusammengezogen, nicht? Wir sind absolut mit Favorit auf den Aufstieg. Nein, du kannst es ja im Moment nicht leugnen. Also vierte in der Tabelle, es läuft einfach gut. Wir haben, ich finde, ein stabiles Gerüst und tauschen ab und zu mal durch und sind zu Hause. Und auswärts lassen wir uns nicht irgendwie aus dem Konzept bringen. Ich kann mich jetzt hier nicht hinstellen und sagen, wir werden oder wir wollen mit oben nichts zu tun haben, um Gottes Willen. Aber da sind halt auch noch andere Mannschaften, wir sprechen dann auch im Laufe der Sendung, glaube ich, noch über die eine oder andere Mannschaft, die auch wissen, wie die zweite Liga geht. Und wir kommen aus einer sehr, sehr schlechten Saison letztes Jahr. Die war dann am Ende noch Platz 11. Aber wenn man sich anguckt, wie knapp das zu Platz 15 war, und da standen wir lange Zeit da unten, dann ist es nicht so, dass wir, wir sind nicht mehr der Bundesligist, der abgestiegen ist aus der ersten Liga und jetzt in der zweiten Liga nur noch darauf wartet, wieder aufzusteigen. Wir sind ein Zweitligist, der viele Jahre inzwischen leider da schon spielt. Wir hatten ja einen Ausflug noch mal ganz kurz in die erste Liga, aber natürlich keine Nachhaltigkeit in dem Ausflug. Und von daher müssen wir uns ein bisschen einreihen. Aber ja, es ist halt auch, da müssen wir auch ganz klar sagen, es ist keine Saison, wo Bremen und Schalke abgestiegen sind, sondern es sind Bielefeld und Fürth. Und die beiden haben halt auch nicht den besten Start so hingelegt in die Saison. Und bis die dann vielleicht da oben wieder rankommen, ist auch noch ein bisschen hin. Das heißt, ich will das jetzt auch nicht von mir wegschieben, dass wir da oben noch ein bisschen rumdoktern können. Aber ganz sicher bin ich mir auch noch nicht.
Gut, ich meine, da kannst du jetzt ja auch noch in neuen Spieltagen auch noch keine verlässlichen Prognosen machen. Aber sag mir doch mal, was hat sich denn da verändert? Also wenn Sebastian sagt, ja, die haben ja wirklich viele Spieler im Kader, die auch den Ball laufen lassen können, da bin ich wiederum zusammengezogen und dachte mir, huch, was ist denn da bei Hannover 96 passiert? Also ich habe bisher immer die Transfer-Bemühungen, das war eher so Slapstick, hängt natürlich auch so ein bisschen mit den Leuten auf Twitter zusammen, denen ich da folge. Also herzlichen Grüße an Ansgar unter anderem, der das immer ausweidet und immer die Aussagen der Sportdirektoren und von Martin Kindt dann gegen die Transfers schneidet, möchte ich jetzt mal sagen. Es scheint ja dann in dieser Transferperiode besser geklappt zu haben.
Ja, hat es tatsächlich. Also du hast auch mit dem, was du da vorgesagt hast, recht. Wir haben viele abenteuerliche Transfers getätigt in den letzten Jahren, aber dieses Jahr suche ich die noch. Also nicht, dass ich darauf warte, dass sie wirklich kommen, aber ich finde sie im Moment auch nicht. Wir haben Harvard Nielsen, Sebastian hat es gerade angesprochen, den hat der Trainer quasi mitgebracht aus Fürth. Der spielt in meinen Augen eine Bombensaison, ist vielleicht der wichtigste Spieler, den wir haben, ist einer von denen, die etwas machen, was ich total vermisst habe. Wenn der einen Ball am Fuß hat, dann geht der auch mal auf den Gegenspieler, läuft er auf den Zu, der versucht, den mal auszudribbeln, der geht ins 1 gegen 1, der versucht nicht wieder hinten rumzupassen und zu gucken, bis irgendwo eine Lücke ist, sondern der will die Lücke selber reißen, der hat selber eine Idee. Das macht mir mega viel Spaß, dem zuzugucken. Im Moment so ein bisschen mein Lieblingsspieler in der ganzen Truppe. Das ist nicht der Einzige, der neu dazugekommen ist und der wirklich was bringt. Ich baller jetzt einfach ein paar Namen rein. Fabian Kunze im Mittelfeld gesetzt, auch wenn er fleißig mit seinen gelben Karten war. Die Fünfte lässt dann noch ein bisschen auf sich warten. Phil Neumann spielt Innenverteidigung. Das ist der, der gegen Sandhausen fast die gelb-rote Karte gekriegt hätte, die dann aber noch mal zurückgenommen wurde. Und macht das in dieser Dreierkette neben Boerner und neben Kreinsch auch gut. Also der schaltet sich ab und zu auch mal nach vorne ein. Auch das erfreut mein Herz dann immer, wenn so ein Innenverteidiger fast so im alten Lucio-Style sich vorne mit einmischt, ist auch angekommen. Dazu Enzo Leopold gerade angesprochen. Den haben wir ja aus Freiburg von der zweiten Mannschaft vom SC Freiburg geholt. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Und ist jetzt auch fest in dieser Mannschaft gewesen für diese vier Spiele. Mal gucken, wie es nach der Länderspielpause aussieht. Der ist natürlich noch mega jung. Der ist 21, hat nicht viel Erfahrung im Profifußball. Aber trotz allem auch das eine gute Verpflichtung. Die beiden, vorhin auch angesprochenen, Max Bisufschkow und Louis Schaub. Mal gucken, da fehlt mir noch so ein bisschen die Ernsthaftigkeit. Ich glaube spielerisch sind die beiden echt richtig gut und wahrscheinlich sogar besser und natürlich auch weiter als zum Beispiel Enzo Leopold. Aber ich glaube Leitl hat die aus einem guten Grund rausgenommen. Und das war dann dieses mit der Konzentration, mit dem Einsatz willen. Und wenn das noch ein bisschen gedreht wird, dann haben wir da noch zwei weitere im Mittelfeld, die richtig liefern können. Und dann der einzige Spieler, der Geld gekostet hat bei der diesesjährigen Transferperiode, Derek Köhne aus Holland geholt von Willem Twey, linker Verteidiger. Für mich der Hopp oder Top Spieler, oder vielleicht ja doch, kann man so sagen, der Hopp oder Top Spieler, jedes Spiel wieder aufs Neue. Der ist nach vorne, ist der Weltklasse. Nach hinten ist er derjenige gewesen, der beim 3 zu 2 gegen Sandhausen auch schon wieder drei Schritte mindestens zu spät war. Dementsprechend kriegen wir dieses 3 zu 2 rein, was das Spiel dann noch mal spannend macht. Es ist einfach interessant, was wir an Spielern geholt haben. Ich finde, die sind viele Spiele auch schon direkt eingebaut. Das sorgt natürlich dann auch dafür, dass andere im Kader vielleicht nicht ganz so glücklich sind. Grüße an Herrn Kerk, auch an Teuchert, der jetzt gut gegen Braunschweig und Sandhausen wieder im Geschäft war, davor aber relativ stark abgemeldet war. Das heißt, ein paar alte Führungsspieler, ganz vorsichtig dieses Wort mit reingeworfen, sind im Moment nicht die allerglücklichsten, aber das macht nichts, weil der Rest der Mannschaft sehr gut zusammenspielt. Diese Veränderung, die sowohl von Markus Mann als Manager, als auch von Stefan Leitl als Trainer passiert sind, gefallen mir aktuell nach neun Spieltagen außerordentlich gut.
Da scheint auch viel ineinander zu greifen. Man hat das Gefühl, dass Stefan Leitl auch genügend Optionen hat. Alles, was du jetzt gesagt hast, zeugt von einer Breite im Kader, die jetzt auch nicht jeder Zweitligist hat. Das erklärt dann auch, warum es bisher so gut läuft für Hannover, Rang 4 mit 17 Punkten.
Lass mich noch zu Breite ganz kurz was sagen. Ja, aber halt auch leider nicht überall. Ich warte jeden Tag auf mein Handy und warte drauf, dass irgendwann die Nachricht kommt, dass sich einer unserer Innenverteidiger verletzt hat. Und wir dann wieder zurückstellen müssen auf Zweierkette. Weil da sind wir echt richtig, richtig dünn besetzt. Ich hoffe, dass wir da einfach ein bisschen verschont bleiben, was Verletzungen angeht. Was das Mittelfeld und was die Offensive angeht, bin ich voll und ganz bei dir. Das ist okay. Da können wir auf jeden Fall erstmal mit durch die Saison cruisen.
Okay, also damit hätte ich jetzt ehrlicherweise nicht gerechnet. Denn hier auf transfermarkt.de werden mir insgesamt zehn Spieler angezeigt, die Innenverteidiger spielen können angeblich.
Aber wenn wir einen geilen Doer in die Innenverteidigung stellen, dann musst du mich die nächste Woche nicht einladen in Rasenfunk, bitte. Da täuscht transfermarkt.de so ein bisschen. Also wir haben Krahenspörner, Neumann, das sind die drei, die im Moment spielen. Und wenn die nicht spielen, ja klar kannst du so ein Kunze auch, aber dann fehlt ja halt auch im defensiven Mittelfeld. Also Tim Weibrecht ist leider verletzt, das wäre eigentlich die Nummer 4 gewesen. Läuft so unter Jungen und aufstrebend und vielleicht wird da mal was draus. Aber alle anderen, die da so ein gelbes IV stehen haben, nee, lass mal. Erst mal. Vielleicht später noch, aber jetzt erst mal noch nicht.
Na gut, ich meine, es ist noch eine lange Saison, aber bisher steht Hannover super da. 17 Punkte jetzt noch in Spieltagen. Damit hat man einen Punkt Rückstand auf Rang 3, zwei Punkte Rückstand auf Rang 2 und vier Punkte Rückstand auf Rang 1 und hat vor allem jetzt einfach eine richtig gute Phase in den letzten sechs Spielen. Fünf Siege, ein Unentschieden. Das Unentschieden war das gegen Braunschweig, was ja immer so ein besonderes Spiel ist. Da wollen wir jetzt nicht drüber reden, keine Sorge. Ich habe schon den Anfangssäufzer wahrgenommen. Wir sparen das aus. Sehr gut. Also das ist die Situation bei Hannover 96, Sandhausen wiederum. Ich habe es schon gesagt, Punkt gleich mit Braunschweig. Und Bielefeld auf Rang 15 aktuell über Sandhausen. Da werden wir sicherlich auch nochmal mehr sprechen in einem der nächsten Kurzpässe. Ehrlicherweise habe ich aber auch das Gefühl, man wiederholt sich da. Es ist alles immer das Gleiche bei Sandhausen. Es ist halt einfach Alois-Schwarz-Fußball mit Kim Zombie vorne drin. Das ist jetzt vielleicht gerade so das, was man wissen muss. Vielleicht bin ich jetzt ein bisschen ketzerisch. Ich weiß nicht. Luis würde es mir dann schon sagen nach dieser Sendung. Lasst uns über Bielefeld sprechen, denn da haben wir ja einen der zwei Absteiger, die eben jetzt schon einen so großen Rückstand auf die Aufstiegsränge haben, dass die sich gar nicht mit dem Aufstieg befassen können eigentlich. Also für Bielefeld sind es ja aktuell 13 Punkte auf Platz 1 und 10 Punkte auf Rang 3. Und das, obwohl man jetzt Sebastian gegen Kiel gewinnen konnte, und das, obwohl Klos fehlt, schafft es trotzdem, die Arminia vier Tore zu erzielen. Ist das der Daniel Scherneck-Effekt?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich würde sagen, in dem Fall, in dem konkreten Spiel, ist es eher der Robin-Hack-Effekt.
Willst du etwas sagen, dass es hilft, nach 20 Sekunden das 1 zu 0 zu schießen?
Nein, um Gottes Willen. Doch, das hilft natürlich. Aber was wir auch da wieder gesehen haben, das wollte ich eigentlich gerade eben auch noch sagen beim Hannover-Spiel, hat auch wieder so lange gedauert, bis die Entscheidung da kam. Ich fand das mega nervig an diesem Spieltag. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das auch mal eine subjektive Wahrnehmung, aber an dem Spieltag war es meiner Meinung nach wieder extrem oft und auch oft in Situationen, wo man sich denkt, es ist doch eigentlich total klar, wie kann es jetzt so lange dauern. In dem Fall fand ich es total gut, dass der VOR da eingegriffen hat, weil in der Situation war es total schwierig für den Schiedsrichter, glaube ich, in der Situation das live zu sehen, von wem jetzt der Ball kam in dem Moment. Von daher, man kann ja oft darüber streiten, aber ich glaube gerade in der Situation beim 1-0 für Bielefeld war es gut. Und dann hat Hake auch wieder vorbereitet, deswegen der Robin-Hakeffekt, aber auch schlecht verteidigt von Kiel. Von daher, Bielefeld, die kommen ja jetzt auch erst so langsam in den Tritt, und ich bin echt mal gespannt, wie das da weitergeht, weil die habe ich echt auch schon so ein bisschen durchrauschen sehen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch da geht.
Ich eigentlich nicht. Also ich war tatsächlich ein bisschen enttäuscht von Bielefeld, dass sie so schlecht in die Saison gestartet sind. Vielleicht hat der Trainerwechsel wirklich jetzt so einen kleinen Wendepunkt gebracht. Ganz kurz noch was zu diesem VR-Ding. Also wenn du von vier Minuten Fußball drei Minuten dabei zuguckst, was der Schiedsrichter macht, ist das wirklich problematisch. Ich wollte mich gar nicht so doll aufregen heute über den Video Schiedsrichter, aber es waren wirklich diesen Spieltag viele Szenen, die sehr, sehr lange gedauert haben. Für das 96-Spiel kann ich sagen, aber dann auch richtig entschieden wurden in zweiter Instanz. Okay, das muss man dann vielleicht auch in Kauf nehmen, aber irgendwie so richtig geil finde ich es weiterhin auch nicht. Ganz kurz noch zum Spiel Bielefeld gegen Kiel. 11 zu 31 Torschüsse habe ich irgendwo gehört und gelesen. 11 zu 31, habe ich gesagt, das kann natürlich nicht richtig sein, habe ich die nächste Website aufgemacht, da stand 12 zu 32, wurde mir immer schwindeliger. Aber genau so ein Spiel war das halt auch. Also das war beste Fußballunterhaltung und die mit den 11 Torschüssen war übrigens Bielefeld, die daraus vier Tore machen. Also können wir dann auch über solche Sachen wie Effizienz und so weiter reden. Torwart glaube ich auch nicht ganz glücklich, der Dehne von Kiel. Aber gut, am Ende Bielefeld jetzt ohne Klos. Max hat es gesagt, können sie vier Tore schießen. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das ein Zeichen in die richtige Richtung. Oder aus Kieler Sicht, nach 3-0 Rückstand noch mal auf 3-2 rankommen, ist jetzt auch nicht das Allerschlechteste für die Laune vermutlich, auch wenn am Ende natürlich kein Punkt mitgenommen wird. Ist es aber so, dass die Kieler, ich weiß nicht, die machen so einen grundsoliden Eindruck auf mich irgendwie diese Saison.
Ja, die hatten ja auch irgendwie dann streckenweise nach dem 3-2 nochmal 70% Ballbesitz. Also die haben da echt nochmal auch Gas gegeben und waren da auch am Zug. Und dann ist ja auch dieses 4-2 dann für Bielefeld gefallen, nachdem es eigentlich vorher nochmal eine Situation gab, wo es hätte vielleicht sogar nochmal 11 Meter geben können für Kiel nach Foul am Bartels. Ja, also ganz, ganz schwierige Situation in dem Moment. Und dann kippt eben das Spiel dann doch in Richtung, oder was heißt kippt in Richtung Bielefeld, dann macht Bielefeld den Sack zu. Aber es hätte eben dann doch nochmal vielleicht in die andere Richtung kippen können. Also Kiel hat da kein schlechtes Spiel gemacht auf der Alm.
Aber absolut. Also 69 Prozent Ballbesitz war es am Ende bei einer Passquote von 85 Prozent. Im Gegenzug dazu Bielefeld Passquote 67 Prozent. Das gibt so ein bisschen Hinweis darauf, wie diese Partie lief. Und ich glaube, wenn mich jemand fragen würde, welches Team soll man sich gerade angucken in der 2. Mäder Bundesliga? Also Heustern Kiel wäre einer der Kandidaten, die ich da nennen würde. Bei Kiel ist immer was los und Kiel, das ist so, die schaffen es ganz gut, glaube ich, im Kopf sich vom Spielstand zu lösen. Es ist eigentlich egal, wie sie zurückliegen, sie spielen einfach immer weiter.
Auch wenn Sexschweifel-Patterbord steht.
Ja, na ja, aber ist doch so eigentlich, oder? Also es wird einfach stoisch weiter fröhlich nach vorne gespielt und man hat Spaß dran und man macht das schnell und relativ passig. Und du hast den ewigen Finn Bartels, der irgendwie den, ich weiß nicht, den George Clooney-Effekt hat. Mit jedem grauen Haar wird er noch hübscher, auch wenn das jetzt sehr oberflächlich ist, aber es fasziniert mich einfach. Ich gucke ihm aus sehr vielen Gründen gerne zu und freue mich irgendwie auch immer für ihn, wenn er dann Erfolg hat. Wie er auch in diesem Spiel hat er auch wieder das 3 zu 2 dann gemacht. Also Kiel ist einfach so eine Never-Give-Up-Mannschaft.
Ist ja schön, wie du das sagst. Ich glaube, die Kieler Fans werden das sicher auch gerne hören, dass man einfach immer fröhlich nach vorne spielt, egal wie es steht. Dann kriegt man halt vier Dinge, aber egal, man hat halt fröhlich weiter nach vorne gespielt.
Ja, das ist halt mein neutraler Blick, ne? Aber ein bisschen ist quasi –Finn Bartels ist –oder Heustern Kiel ist der Rick Astley der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Ein Never-Gib-You-Up.
Um noch ein bisschen Wein in den –nee, Wasser in den Wein, Kieler Wein zu schütten. Gibt's in Kiel Wein? Na ist egal. Die drei Siege, die Kiel geholt hat, das ist das, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, waren zu Hause gegen Braunschweig, zu Hause gegen Sandhausen und in Magdeburg. Also geschlagen, was zu schlagen ist, aber so wirklich beeindruckende Siege waren, ist noch nicht dabei. Im Gegenteil, wenn sie dann verlieren –du hast es ja gerade gesagt, dann scheppert es halt auch mal ordentlich.
Ja, okay, das stimmt natürlich. Aber aktuell steht Heustein sehr gut da. 12 Punkte aus neun Spielen. Das ist aktuell Rang 8. Und am neunten Spieltag beginnt ja die Tabelle, so langsam dann doch etwas auszusagen über den Saisonsverlauf, wie er bei Bielefeld auch. Die eben, wie schon angesprochen, bei acht Punkten jetzt dann stehen nach diesem Sieg, der den Bielefeldern sehr, sehr gut getan hat. Anders ist das beim ersten FC Nürnberg, über die wir jetzt sprechen wollen. Die stehen auf Rang 13 mit nur zehn Punkten. Und da sind keine Punkte mit dazu gekommen, weil man Tobi bei Darmstadt verloren hat mit 0 zu 2. Und Darmstadt wiederum konnte endlich mal wieder gewinnen. Also, endlich jetzt großen Anführungszeichen, aber es gab drei Unentschieden in Folge. Und jetzt konnte mal wieder ein Dreier eingefahren werden. Wie war denn dieses Spiel?
Das war nicht so unterhaltsam. Also, wenn wir gerade von 11 zu 31 Torschüssen gesprochen haben, hier waren es 6 zu 9 oder so aus Sicht von Darmstadt. Aber das war so von Darmstadt gefühlt so ein No-Fun-Allowed-Game. Also, die haben keine Späße zugelassen in dem Spiel. Haben früh das 1-0 gemacht. Das war Megavollage von Brandon Manu. Und dann dieser eingesprungene Außenrist von Kempe. Ein herrliches Tor, das muss man ganz klar sagen. Und dann legen sie das 2 zu 0 nach, nach 27 Minuten. Und dann haben sie gesagt, bis hierhin und nicht weiter, Freunde. Also, Darmstadt ist einfach ziemlich abgeklärt, habe ich das Gefühl. Die wissen, wie man Fußball spielt, die wissen, wie man den Gegner diszipliniert und mit starken Zweikämpfen oder mit intensiv geführten Zweikämpfen genau da hält, wo es nötig ist und wo es passt. Nürnberg hat am Ende 62 Prozent Beibesitz, aber gefühlt nichts wirklich Beeindruckendes rausgeholt. Also, Darmstadt hat das –ich sage es fast ungern –wie eine klasse Mannschaft, wie eine Spitzenmannschaft runtergespielt. Es ist wirklich beeindruckend, wie die das gemacht haben.
Ja, und die haben auch wirklich so verabgetan. Also, dieses Kempel-Tor, das ist wirklich Zucker, wie ihr das Ding da mit dem Außenriss da reinschweißt. Das hat fast schon so ein bisschen Harlan-Style, kann man sagen. Dann Tietz ist auch immer mal wieder wirklich sehr, sehr abgeklärter Goal-Getter, auch da mit dem Kopfball nach der Ecke zum 2-0. Zwischendurch auch noch mal ein bisschen Glück, weil da hätte man vielleicht auch noch mal über den Elber für den Klub sprechen können, da nach dem Handspiel nachher. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie viele Minuten das war. Da kann man vielleicht drüber streiten, aber wie es halt immer so ist. Ansonsten fand ich eigentlich eine ganz lustige Beschreibung, no fun allowed. Ich meine, dann ist es eben humorlos, aber ich glaube, humorlos nehmen sie die drei Punkte auch ganz gerne mit. Was hingegen nicht so ganz witzig war, war diese Geschichte mit dem Becherwurf gegen Kempe. Das ist natürlich auch kein Fun.
Also Kempe wurde aus dem Nürnberg-Block mit einem Becher beworfen und ein zweites Wurf-Werkzeug –ein Wurfinstrument, also sah ein bisschen nach einem Feuerzeug aus –hat ihn noch knapp verfehlt. Das wird sicherlich in der Strafe nachziehen und die ist auch mehr als nur gerechtfertigt, weil das hat einfach überhaupt nichts im Sport verloren. Und ist so ein bisschen der –ich sag's jetzt einfach so, wie es ist –der Scheißhaufen auf einer schlechten Leistung auf einem beschissenen Tag von Nürnberg. Ich meine, wir haben schon gesagt, sechs Schüsse Darmstadt, neun Schüsse Nürnberg, aber auf Seiten des Clubs kein einziger Aufstor. Und ich werd nicht aus dem Club schlau, muss ich sagen. Also, Tobi, was ist da los? Die haben erst einmal gewonnen in dieser Saison.
Hast du dich jetzt in meine Aufzeichnung eingearbeitet hier? Ich werde nicht so ganz schlau aus Nürnberg. Steht genau an diesen Worten in meiner Aufzeichnung. Ich versteh's halt wirklich nicht so ganz, was da passiert. Drei Siege, eine unentschieden, fünf Niederlagen. Ich hatte mehr von ihnen erwartet. Letzte Saison waren sie fast die ganze Zeit im oberen Drittel mit dabei. Ich weiß nicht, am Ende dann irgendwie noch Achter geworden. Das war ja dann alles sehr wild da in den letzten Spieltagen in der 2. Liga. Ich habe tatsächlich auch mehr erwartet von Nürnberg in dieser Saison. Ich glaube aber, dass die nächsten beiden Spiele vielleicht tatsächlich so ein bisschen die Richtung vorgehen werden. Da spielt man gegen Karlsruhe, da spielt man gegen Kiel. Die sind, wenn man auf die Tabelle guckt, beide in der Nähe. Das heißt, man kann da Anschlüsse wiederherstellen, bzw. die Gegner überholen in der Tabelle, dann auch deutlich entspannter. In Nürnberg ist man glaube ich nicht zufrieden, wenn man 13. ist. Da sind wir uns einig. Der Blick auf die Tabelle ist bei sowas dann auch irgendwie wichtig, auch wenn es nur zwei Punkte sind bis Platz 8. Aber die muss man halt auch holen und da muss man sich dann ein bisschen vorschieben. Von daher, ich würde sagen, wir geben Nürnberg noch zwei Spieltage und dann gucken wir uns mal an, ob die Fahrt eher nach oben oder eher nach unten geht.
Dann gibt es wieder einen Schwerpunkt hier. Aber es scheint mir so ein bisschen das alte Problem wieder zu sein. Also Nürnberg hatte schon in der letzten Saison eine gewisse Stürmer-Thematik, möchte ich sie jetzt mal nennen. Und ich glaube, das ist zumindest ein Teil des Problems bei Nürnberg. Bei neun Toren nach neun Spielen, da ist nur Regensburg schlechter und man ist gleichauf mit Rostock. Und bei Rostock habe ich ja noch hervorgehoben, wie effizient man es geschafft hat, diese wenigen Tore in Punkte umzumünzen. Das ist halt einfach schwierig, auch wenn man bei Darmstadt mal verlieren kann.
Ja, und wenn man überlegt neun Tore und davon haben sie zwei in Braunschweig geschossen, haben sie vier zu zwei verloren, davon haben sie zwei auf St. Pauli geschossen, da haben sie drei zu zwei verloren. Es hilft dir auch nichts, wenn du die Tore schießt und davon nichts mitnimmst. Also das ist sicherlich ein großes Problem, Tore schießen. Wer vier Zwei gegen Braunschweig verliert, ich glaube, es wird keine gute Saison.
Aber Max, du hast gesagt, es ist ein Teil des Problems. Klar, es kommt natürlich auch darauf an, in den richtigen Momenten die Tore zu schießen. Und dann bringt es dir natürlich nichts, wenn du zwei Dinge schießt und dann noch vier Zwei verlierst. Aber das gegen Darmstadt, da hat die Offensive ja quasi gar nicht wirklich stattgefunden. Du hast ja auch schon gesagt, also keinen Schuss aufs Tor. Und der beste Schuss ging irgendwie, glaube ich, auch drei, vier Meter rechts am Pfosten vorbei. Also da ist dann durchaus noch Ausbaubedarf in der Offensive.
Aber absolut. Ich sehe schon, über den Club müssen wir bald mal wieder ausführlicher sprechen. Ausbaubedarf in der Offensive hat dagegen nicht der Jan aus Regensburg. Und das, obwohl man auch nur sieben Schüsse abgegeben hat im Spiel gegen den FC St. Pauli. Aber davon waren zwei drin. Und deswegen gewinnt Regensburg dieses Spiel mit 2 zu 0. Und St. Pauli, glaube ich, stellt sich die Frage, Sebastian, warum verlieren wir in diesem Jahr so komisch unsere Spiele? Also ich habe jetzt nicht jedes Spiel von St. Pauli gesehen, aber mein Gefühl war immer so, wenn sie besser waren als der Gegner, haben sie verloren. Und wenn sie so auf Augenhöhe oder schlechter waren, haben sie manchmal auch noch irgendwie gewonnen.
Das ist lustigerweise auch genau mein Eindruck von allem, was ich bisher von St. Pauli so gesehen habe. Sie sind ja auch gegen Regensburg wieder ganz gut gestartet und mit einem Freistoß direkt an den Pfosten. Und dann halt echt so auch ein fragwürdiger Elfmeter. Da wäre ich jetzt auch mal gespannt auf eure Meinung, wie ihr das gesehen habt, ob ihr den Elfer, der dann zum 1-0 durch Albers geführt hat, ob ihr den geben würdet oder nicht. Vielleicht steigen wir damit mal kurz ein.
Für mich kein Elfmeter.
Ja, ich finde vor allem, also das war doch die Szene, wo der Schiedsrichter quasi gar nichts entschieden hat auf dem Feld, oder? Und auf den Videobeweis gewartet hat oder vermische ich da ganz?
Der Ball klickelte dann so ins Aus und ich glaube, dann macht es knickknack im Ohr vom Schiedsrichter und dann hat er gesagt, jetzt müssen wir uns das mal angucken. Und dann, warum auch immer, Elfmeter.
Es ist aber auch eine ganz komische Szene, da er geht da in den Zweikampf rein, dann trifft er ihn erst nicht, dann trifft er irgendwie den Ball und dann trifft er ihn doch. Also es ist knifflig, aber ich würde auch eigentlich eher sagen, kein Elfmeter.
Also vor allem halt keine klare Fehlentscheidung. Wenn er es gepfiffen hätte, na wobei ehrlich gesagt, nee ich finde auch so, dass es kein Elfmeter war. Du hast es eigentlich perfekt geschrieben. Er trifft erst den Ball und dann den Gegenspieler und dann ist es für mich eigentlich relativ eindeutig. Wir hatten bei Mailand gegen Napoli eine ganz ähnliche Szene, wo es genau anders rum war, wo man gedacht hat, der Verteidiger hätte dem ballgespielt und dann in der Wiederholung siehst du, nein, er spielt den Fuß des Stürmers und dann trifft der Fuß des Stürmers den Ball. Das war genau umgedreht und so, wie das eine dann zu Recht Strafstoß war in Mailand, würde ich jetzt sagen, hier in Regensburg war es keiner und das war ja wahrscheinlich auch die Connection, die einfach auch alle anderen hatten, als sie diese Szene in Mailand gesehen haben, dass sie gesagt haben, aber in Regensburg war das doch…
Ja, wenn man an Mailand denkt, denkt man sofort immer auch an den Jahren, auf jeden Fall.
Ach, ich lebe ein komisches Leben, ich gebe es ja zu. Gut, aber 2 zu 0 war es jetzt am Ende. Was fangen wir jetzt damit an? Vielleicht aus Sicht erstmal von Regensburg, das ist das Positive, denn Regensburg tumt ja dieser 3er sehr gut. 11 Punkte hat man jetzt. Tobi, wie steht der Jan da in deinen Augen?
Ja, du hast es eingeleitet mit, ich glaube, kein Ausbaubedarf in der Offensive hat Jan Regensburg. Die hatten davor sechs Spiele, kein Tor geschossen. Dementsprechend auch sechs Spiele, kein Sieg eingefahren. Das war zwingend notwendig, dass die jetzt diese Punkte holen gegen St. Pauli. Und wenn man sechs Spiele in Folge nicht getroffen hat, ist jetzt auch keine Meisterleistung zu sagen. Das ist vorne in dieser Saison absolut hakt bei denen. Und wenn wir uns an die letzte Saison kurz erinnern von Regensburg, da waren die lange Zeit auch mal ganz, ganz oben mit dabei. Und am Ende sind sie 15. geworden. Ich glaube, diesen Trend setzen sie aktuell so ein bisschen fort und haben damit dann halt auch mit St. Pauli was gemeinsam. Die waren auch besser in der Hinrunde als in der Rückrunde. Enttäuscht mich tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen, weil ich dachte, vielleicht fangen sie sich wieder, aber es scheint eher so eine Gesamtjahresbilanz 2022 zu sein, die dann echt nicht so gut ist bei St. Pauli. Ich glaube, zwei Siege, vier Unentschieden, drei Niederlagen. Regensburg 11. St. Pauli 12. Ich glaube, so ein Spiel war das auch. Ich habe, als ich mir das dann alles nochmal angeguckt habe, da habe ich gedacht, ach, das wäre es jetzt eigentlich nicht nötig gewesen, um sich dieses Spiel nochmal damit intensiver zu beschäftigen. Es war kein gutes Spiel und ich finde, die stehen halt da, wo sie hingehören in der Tabelle.
11. und 12. irgendwo im Nirgendwo. Da steht Regensburg und da steht ja auch St. Pauli, Sebastian. Die stehen nämlich auf Rang 12 dahinter. Kannst du da den Finger in die Wunde legen, woran es liegt, dass das, was Tobi gerade gesagt hat, nämlich dass man ja in der Kalenderjahr-Tabelle einfach bei beiden keine so gute Tendenz erkennen kann?
Ja, ich wollte gerade schon sagen, ich frage mich echt, was mit Pauli nach dieser Herbstmeisterschaft passiert ist, weil die haben ja echt geilen Fußball gespielt und waren echt so auf dem Weg in die Bundesliga. Und dann? Also ich frage mich da auch, also das ist schon richtig sozusagen, dass man es aufs Kalenderjahr sieht. Also das ist ja echt eine Mannschaft und auch wir hatten es ja gerade auch schon davon, dass sie eigentlich auch dann die Spiele verloren haben, wo sie eigentlich gefühlt, also auch optisch gesehen, besser waren. Und man kommt einfach nicht drauf, was da passiert ist. Eigentlich eine Mannschaft, mit der auch ich immer gerechnet habe, die auch wirklich Fußball spielen kann. Und dann dieser Einbruch und auch wirklich dieser dauerhafte Einbruch. Also ich kann mir das echt nicht erklären, was da passiert ist. Ob es irgendwie an dem dauerhaften Regen in Hamburg liegt oder an der steifen Prise.
Weiß ich dazu überrascht oder wie man es vorher sonst immer so sonnig war in Hamburg?
Ja, das kann natürlich sein. Für mich unerklärlich, was mit St. Pauli passiert ist. Also ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann es echt nicht erklären.
Also ich notiere mir, wir haben Schwerpunkt Nürnberg, bald mal wieder auch ein Schwerpunkt St. Pauli. Tatsächlich in der Kalender-Jahr-Tabelle von den Teams, die 25 Spiele gemacht haben. Ansonsten ist es ein bisschen krumm. Es ist ja in Regensburg das schlechteste Team und St. Pauli das viertst schlechteste Team. Übrigens das drittschlechteste Team der 1. EFC Nürnberg. Also da gibt es Erklärungsbedarf, dem werden wir uns mal demnächst widmen hier im Kurzpass. Jetzt wollen wir allerdings erstmal auf das Spiel des 1. FC Heidenheim gegen den 1. FC Kaiserslautern blicken. Es war ein Jubiläumsspiel für den Trainer der Heidenheimer und er hat ein 2 zu 2 sehen dürfen in diesem Spiel, Frank Schmidt. Wie ist das zustande gekommen, deiner Meinung nach? Und was sagt dieses 2 zu 2 in Unterzahl über den 1. FC Kaiserslautern aus, Sebastian?
Also ich würde erst mal sagen, dass selbst wenn man ein neutraler Zuschauer ist, glaube ich, hat man ein echt gutes Zweitligaspiel gesehen. Da war echt viel drin auf beiden Seiten. Es war, glaube ich, eines Jubiläums von 15 Jahren auf der Trainerbank. Würde ich, auch wenn er sich das sicherlich hätte anders vorgestellt, Herr Schmidt, und er gerne dieses Spiel gewonnen hätte. Aber Heidenheim hat da relativ trocken und humorlos durch Beste das 1-0 geschossen. Der FCK hat es aber dann geschafft, relativ schnell wieder zurückzukommen. Das ist irgendwie etwas, was den FCK in diesem Jahr, in dieser Saison auch auszeichnet, dass man so das Gefühl hat, egal was passiert und egal, ob die Mannschaft in Rückstand gerät, sie hat das Potenzial, immer wieder zurückzuschlagen. Das hatte man ganz, ganz viele Jahre jetzt beim FCK nicht mehr. Und jetzt ist es im Moment wirklich so, dass man das eigentlich so recht entspannt auch hinnimmt, wenn ein Gegentor fällt, weil man irgendwie weiß, die sind auf jeden Fall in der Lage, noch ein Tor zu schießen und du hast auch endlich mal wieder vorne im Sturm mit Terence Boyd jemanden drin, der wirklich den Namen Stürmer auch verdient hat, der sicherlich auch seine Schwächen hat und in der 2. Liga, würde ich mal sagen, nicht der überragende Überfliegerstürmer ist, aber der einfach abgezockt ist, der weiß, wo er zu stehen hat, der eine wahnsinnig gute Lufthoheit hat, der die Bälle runter pflückt, der fast jedes Kopfballduell gewinnt und dann eben auch beim 1-1 da dieses Gewusel im 16er am besten über Blick hoch steigt und das Ding reinköpft und dann eben am Ende auch nochmal das 2-2 schießt. Man könnte jetzt sagen, okay, ein bisschen viel unentschieden, aber wir lassen es erstmal noch bei dem Spiel bleiben. Dann haben wir eben auch noch die Situation, dass der FCK auch noch ein Spieler hat wie den Marlon Ritter, der, wie ich immer so schön sage, relativ nah an Genie und Wahnsinn ist, weil er eben einen total verrückten Rückpass spielt, so eine hohe Bogenlampe zurück auf Andreas Lute, der dann da ein bisschen spät reagiert, rauskommt und dann seinen Gegenspieler umsetzt. Die Konsequenz war dann eine rote Karte für Lute und ein Freistoß, der dann zum 2 zu 1 durch Busch geführt hat. Sehr schöner Freistoß, keine Frage. Da kam dann Afton Spalic, der Ersatzkeeper, rein, der konnte dann da nur mehr oder weniger hinterher schauen. War ein schönes Tor. 2-1. Und dann wiederum hat Malon Ritter eben durch eine sehr, sehr schöne Vorarbeit dazu beigetragen, dass Terence Boyd sein zweites Tor an dem Tag geschossen hat und dann das Ganze am Ende auch dann bei den 2-2 geblieben ist, obwohl man sagen muss, dass der FCK trotz Unterzahl wirklich dann am Ende auch mehr fürs Spiel gemacht hat und man wirklich das Gefühl hatte, der FCK möchte dieses Spiel eigentlich mehr gewinnen als Heidenheim und ich glaube, am Ende die Heidenheimer zufriedener sein konnten mit diesem Unentschieden als der FCK. Von daher, ja, ich würde sagen, ein sehr, sehr munteres Spiel, was, glaube ich, vor allem für neutrale Zuschauer Spaß gemacht hat, zuzuschauen. Würde ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten, aber das könnt ihr mir jetzt erzählen, wie ihr das gesehen habt.
Ich will da nicht widersprechen. Also ich fand es auch, das war wirklich ein unterhaltsames Spiel und ich glaube, 2-2 geht auch in Ordnung. Sebastian hat es vorhin gesagt, Kaiserslautern mit Rückständen –ich habe das dann nochmal nachgeguckt –sechsmal in Rückstand gewesen, daraus ein Sieg, vier Unentschieden gemacht und nur einmal verloren. Also sieben Punkte nach Rückstand noch geholt, das ist Bestwert in der zweiten Liga. Deshalb, ja, das ist unterhaltsam, das machen die Garten nicht so schlecht, die Lauterner diese Saison. Und was das Spiel angeht, ja, das hat, glaube ich, natürlich auch wirklich viel mit der roten Karte für Lute zu tun gehabt, dass das Spiel am Ende so gelaufen ist, wie es ist, also sowohl das 2 zu 1, was ja dazu führte, dass das 2 zu 1 kam, als dann auch das Lautern, glaube ich, diese, ich weiß nicht, ich bin ja immer nicht so hier Mentalitätstruppe und so, aber ich glaube, das ist schon, das ist schon so eine kleine Drecksgruppe, die mit so was dann auch wirklich besser wird und die sich daran, an solchen Spielen dann, ja ich will nicht sagen ergötzen kann, aber so ein bisschen Spaß dran hat im Rückstand und dann alle kämpfen, das können die Lauter gut und natürlich, der Blick auf die Tabelle sagt es ja auch, die sind jetzt siebter, die haben diesen Lauf und diesen Schwung, den man in Magdeburg und in Braunschweig vielleicht nicht ganz so mitgenommen hat, außer aus dem Aufstieg, die haben den mitgenommen und deshalb steht Lautern auch im Moment so gut da, wie sie da stehen.
Ja, obwohl man so viele Unentschieden jetzt gesammelt hat, du hast es gerade schon angesprochen, Sebastian, die letzten vier Spiele waren unentschieden, das heißt, es könnte sogar noch besser gelaufen sein für den FCK, aber woran kann man denn das begründen, dass man eben diese Resilienz hat und dass man so gut in diese Saison gestartet ist und das ist jetzt nach neun Spieltagen natürlich immer noch eine Momentaufnahme, aber die Fallzahl ist jetzt schon relativ groß von Spielen, wo man gesehen hat. Ja, Kaiserslautern ist einfach nicht so leicht beizukommen und das eben nicht nur zu Hause, was man vielleicht noch ein bisschen erwarten konnte. Betzenberg immer ein ganz besonderes Spielort, sondern auch auswärts.
Ich glaube, man muss da so ein bisschen einen längeren Zeitraum jetzt in Betracht ziehen, wenn man das beantworten will. Man muss es wirklich so sehen, dass das eine Entwicklung ist, die jetzt über einen längeren Zeitraum stattgefunden hat, über mehrere Jahre. Der FCK hat sich ja lange Zeit auf dem abstiegenden Ast befunden. Die Formkurve hat nach unten gezeigt, es ging immer weiter runter. Es drohte schon fast der Abstieg aus der 3. Liga. Und da sind wir auch wieder beim Thema Unentschieden. Der FCK hat auch so eine Vorgeschichte mit Unentschieden. 1996 beim ersten Bundesliga-Abstieg waren es die Unentschieden-Könige und sind wegen den Unentschieden abgestiegen. Dann, als es vorletzte Saison in der 3. Liga auch knapp war, da waren auch sehr viele Unentschieden dabei, da wurden böse Erinnerungen wach. Jetzt ist es was anderes. Jetzt hast du zwar auch wieder viele Unentschieden, aber die Mannschaft ist voll im Soll. Aber worauf ich eigentlich raus will, ist, da hat sich jetzt wieder was entwickelt. Da hat wieder auch ein echter Schulterschluss stattgefunden zwischen den Fans und dem Verein. Das ist wieder eine Einheit. Die Leute haben wieder Spaß am Fußball. Das war jetzt wirklich diese Jahre in der 3. Das war schrecklich. Das war schrecklich für die Fans. Das war schrecklich hier für... Gerade da sind wir nochmal ganz kurzer Ausflug an die Kollegen von St. Pauli. Die machen sich immer drüber lustig, dass beim FCK von der Region gesprochen wird. Aber da war wirklich die ganze Region betroffen und traurig. Und jetzt ist eben diese ganze Region wieder total im Fußballfieber, weil es der FCK geschafft hat, die Leute wieder mitzunehmen. Die haben wieder diese FCK-Tugenden an den Tag gelegt. Es wird wieder gekämpft. Es wird gegrätscht. Die Mannschaft gibt sich nicht auf. Es ist eben egal, ob ein Rückstand da ist oder nicht. Die Mannschaft zeigt eben, dass sie willens ist, alles reinzuwerfen und zu kämpfen und sich eben nicht aufzugeben. Und das hat man eben im vergangenen Jahr in der Aufstiegssaison, in der dritten Liga schon gesehen. Und das sieht man jetzt auch wieder. Und man hat eben auch den großen Vorteil, dass der absolute Großteil der Mannschaft zusammengeblieben ist und man eigentlich keinen Leistungsträger abgegeben hat, bis auf Matteo Rab, der jetzt beim HSV auf der Bank sitzen darf. Und man hat dafür eigentlich mit Andreas Lute mehr Qualität, meiner Meinung nach, auf der Torhüterposition bekommen. Von daher kann man sich da echt nicht beschweren. Und ja, also es ist einfach, es fühlt sich, glaube ich, für die Leute auch einfach wieder gut an, FCK-Fan zu sein und da einer Mannschaft zuzuschauen, die Bock auf Fußball hat und die einfach auch weiß, was sie zeigen muss, um bei den Leuten eben einen guten Stand zu haben.
Aber wenn der Kader relativ gleich geblieben ist, dann müssen wir, glaube ich, an der Stelle über Dirk Schuster sprechen, als denjenigen, der da einen Wandel eingeleitet hat.
Ja, also relativ gleich, das ist, ja, da kann man natürlich sagen, ich habe ja Andreas Lute schon angesprochen, du hast mit Erik Durm einen sehr erfahrenen Mann geholt, du hast natürlich auch mit Philipp Clement einen erfahrenen Bundesliga-Spieler auch noch dazu bekommen, also ganz komplett gleich ist es nicht geblieben, aber der Kern der Mannschaft ist gleich geblieben, aber du hast schon recht, Dirk Schuster spielt da eine entscheidende Rolle und das war einfach auch ein ziemlich krasser Move von Sportchef Hengen damals eben vor der Relegation, zu sagen, okay, mit Marco Antwerpen, dem trauen wir das nicht mehr zu, dass der das schafft, von dem verabschieden wir uns jetzt und wir holen jetzt Dirk Schuster als Trainer. Das hätte auch total in die Hose gehen können und dann, ich habe damals schon gesagt, da hat der Thomas Hengen einfach Eier bewiesen. Man muss es so sagen, wie es ist, weil das hätte ihn auch, glaube ich, wenn es nicht gut gegangen wäre, seinen eigenen Job kosten können, aber es hat sich jetzt voll bewährt. Dirk Schuster, man hat das Gefühl, der erreicht die Mannschaft, der stellt sie, auch in der Halbzeitpause, auch wenn der FCK im Rückstand ist, und kommt dann aus der Kabine raus und zeigt auf einmal ein total anderes Gesicht. Also irgendwie schafft es Dirk Schuster dieser Mannschaft, genau das zu sagen, was sie in dem Moment braucht, offenbar. Von daher ist das sicherlich auch ein ganz, ganz großer Verdienst von Dirk Schuster, der ja auch ein erfahrener Mann ist und davon träumen ja viele FCK-Fans auch immer noch, teilweise laut, teilweise leise, der ja auch weiß, wie Durchmarsch funktioniert. Aber da sind wir jetzt mal noch ganz, ganz weit von entfernt und sollten kleinere Brötchen backen. Der FCK steht, glaube ich, meiner Meinung nach genau da, wo er hingehört. Im oberen Drittel, aber auch nicht zu weit oben. Von daher, klar, das eine oder andere unentschieden. Wenn man das noch hätte in seine Richtung biegen können, dann würde es schon wieder ganz anders aussehen. Aber im Endeffekt ist das einzige, worauf man beim FCK schauen sollte. Damit ist man, glaube ich, gut beraten, dass man schnellstmöglich die 40 Punkte erreicht bzw. den Klassen halt sichert und dann kann man mal schauen, wohin die Reise geht.
Ja, vielleicht ist der Kaiserslautern wirklich ein Konkurrent für Hannover 96. Also es ist ja schon erstaunlich, dass wir hier über den siebplatzierten sprechen, bei Lautern, über den viertplatzierten bei Hannover. Deswegen ist jetzt auch Lautern erst zu spät dran, weil wir die Tabelle ja von unten nach oben durchgegangen sind. Und man hatte ja einen Gegner mit Rang 5, der auch aus der oberen Tabellenhälfte kommt. Tobi, wie blickst du auf den Betzenberg?
Ja, ich erinnere mich natürlich an den ersten Spieltag, als wir den Saisonauftakt da hatten. A, mein erster Ausflug zum Betzenberg. Das heißt, ich konnte endlich mal live erleben, wie es dort wirklich so ist. Und B, erinnere ich an eine Mannschaft, die sehr, sehr dreckig gespielt hat. Und das meine ich mit allem Respekt, den man dazu sagen kann. Die Hannover 96 einfach durch unangenehme Spiel, in dem Spiel den Schneid abgekauft. Und jetzt habe ich, während ihr gesprochen habt, noch mal ganz kurz auf die Fairplay-Tabelle geguckt und wenig überraschend. Wer steht auf Platz 1 der 1. FC Kaiserslautern mit zwei roten Karten und 21 Gelben, führen sie die ganze Geschichte hier an. Es ist schon nach Deutschbietern. Kommt jetzt nicht so überraschend für mich, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Aber ich würde es niemals einem Aufsteiger vorwerfen, wenn er sich genau so in solche Spiele reinarbeitet. Vielleicht gehört es dann auch ein bisschen dazu, so eine Spielweise, um auch Rückstände –wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen –wettzumachen. Von daher, ja, ich gucke durchaus interessiert nach Kaiserslautern. Ich bin auch bereit, da ein zweites Mal hinzufahren. Sollten wir nächstes Jahr beide wieder in der gleichen Liga spielen. Ich gehe davon aus, das wird nicht die erste Liga sein, sowohl bei Kaiserslautern als auch bei 96. Da sage ich weiterhin, dass wir nächstes Jahr beide in der zweiten Liga spielen. Ich finde es gut, was Lautern da macht, und es ist schon ein Stück weit beeindruckend, dass es mit Dirk Schuster dazu gekommen ist.
Da musste er sehr genau seine Worte nochmal wählen. Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, Sebastian, dass der FCK ein bisschen die dritte Liga mitgebracht hat in die zweite Liga, wenn ich das so höre.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wir müssen gleich aber auch nochmal bei Tobi nachfragen, was es mit seiner Meinung zu Dirk Schuster auf sich hat. Da kommen wir nicht drum herum. Aber da hast du durchaus recht. Ich glaube, die Mannschaft hat zum einen diesen Schwung aus der dritten Liga und vor allem auch aus der Relegation gegen Dresden mitnehmen können, die Euphorie mitnehmen können und so ein bisschen auch die Spielweise. Wobei ich glaube, dieses Dreckige, das ist nicht unbedingt nur was, was charakteristisch für die dritte Liga ist, sondern das ist eigentlich genau dieser FCK-Fußball, den die Leute auch sehen wollen. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, die Leute wollen sehen, dass die FCK-Jungs ständig irgendeinen umtreten, aber die wollen halt einfach sehen, dass sich reingeworfen wird, dass auch einem eigentlich schon verloren geglaubten Ball hinterhergegrätscht und gerannt wird. Von daher ist es jetzt auch wenig überraschend, dass der FCK die Kartentabelle quasi anführt. Aber wenn das der Weg zum Erfolg für den FCK ist, dann ist das, glaube ich, was alle, die da irgendwie was zu sagen haben, gerne unterschreiben würden. Aber wie gesagt, noch mal der Schwenk zurück zu Tobi und zu Dirk Schuster.
Ich habe das ja bewusst so formuliert. Ich sage mal so, Dirk Schuster ist jetzt nicht zwingend einer der Trainer, die ich mir für Hannover 96 wünsche. Als Kassas Lautern den dann kurz vor Saisonende verpflichtet hat, da habe ich gedacht, da ist Hannover 96 jetzt aber noch mal mit einem blauen Auge davongekommen, dass sie ihn nicht kriegen in der Sommerpause, dass das mit Leitl so geklappt hat, wie es geplant war. Von daher, ich weiß nicht, der überzeugt mich nicht so ganz. Aber aufgestiegen, schon mehrfach, von daher alles gut. Ich beobachte das wirklich mit großen Augen.
Ich meine, wir müssen auch nicht um den Drumherum reden, dass die Begeisterung, als Dirk Schuster für Marco Antwerpen kam, alles andere als groß war. Also man muss sich das nochmal –das ist jetzt lange her, und ich will da jetzt auch nicht einen zu großen Ausflug in die Vergangenheit machen –aber man muss sich nochmal deutlich machen, dass Marco Antwerpen ein unfassbar gutes Standing bei den FCK-Fans hatte und es quasi –also hier ist quasi die Hölle losgebrochen, die ja sehr gut zum FCK und zum Betzenberg auch passt. Als es dann hieß, Marco Antwerpen ist nicht mehr länger FCK-Trainer und Dirk Schuster kommt jetzt, da gab es eigentlich –da hast du, glaube ich, keine Handvoll Leute gefunden, die das gut fanden. Von daher, wenn ich mich jetzt sehr positiv über ihn bisher geäußert habe, dann ist das einfach das, was die Mannschaft bisher zeigt und was mein Eindruck ist. Aber der Start war durchaus schwierig. Natürlich hat ihm dann die erfolgreiche Relegation recht gegeben und total in die Karten gespielt. Aber es wird sich dann eben auch zeigen –wir können alle gespannt sein, wie lange der FCK diese Euphorie weiter mitnehmen kann, wie lange er weiter auf dieser Welle schwappen kann. Und irgendwann, spätestens in der Rückrunde, ist man dann auch mal im harten, zweitläger Alltag angekommen. Dann werden wir mal sehen, wohin die Reise geht. Das ist ja schon was, die Leute drehen hier auch schon wieder durch. Das ist dieses typische, was man auch immer hört, das viel zitierte, schwierige Umfeld. Die Leute werden total schnell nervös, aber auch total schnell euphorisch. Also wenn da mal zwei, drei Spiele verloren wurden, dann ist wieder alles schlecht. Das ist wahrscheinlich bei vielen Vereinen so, aber in Lautern ist das auch so. Das kann ich überhaupt nicht, aber genauso schnell verfällt man rund um den Betzenberg in die Euphorie und damals, als dieser Luxemburger Investor kam, wurde ja schnell vom Thema Champions League gesprochen und jetzt träumt wirklich der ein oder andere davon, dass der FC Kader den Durchmarsch packt und wieder in die Bundesliga aufsteigt. Das ist einfach vor allem nach dieser harten Zeit in der dritten Liga, das wäre einfach too much. Also das wäre einfach zu viel des Guten. Das wäre, glaube ich, kein gesunder Weg. Klar, wenn man jetzt am Ende des Tages dann da steht und sagt, wir stehen jetzt überm Strich und steigen auf, dann werden sie sicher auch nicht sagen, ne, machen wir nicht. Aber man ist echt gut beraten. Natürlich ist es super und es ist ein super Pfund, was man da hat, dass die Leute, dass diese Welle von Sympathie und Euphorie diesen Verein so sehr trägt, aber man ist, glaube ich, echt gut beraten und das machen die Verantwortlichen beim FC Kader auch, da so ein bisschen auf die Bremse zu treten und die backen da auch alle zumindest nach außen hin, kleinere Brötchen und betonen immer wieder, dass nur der nicht-abstieg des Saisons sie sein kann, auch wenn ich selber glaube, dass sie innerlich ein bisschen was anderes wollen, auch aufgrund dessen, was da außen rum so passiert und der Investoren, die da so am Start sind und wie viel Geld die da reinstecken, aber das ist wieder ein anderes Thema.
Das ist allerdings wieder ein anderes Thema. Und wer weiß, vielleicht müssen wir gar nicht auf die Rückrunde warten, bis wir sehen, was passiert, wenn die Euphoriewelle weg ist. Vielleicht müssen wir einfach nur warten, bis die ersten Gelbsperren reinknallen. Der Eric Dome hat schon vier Gelbekarten, Tom Jagd Zimmer und Lobinger jeweils drei. Also das wird jetzt nicht mehr allzu lange dauern. Da lehne ich mich jetzt nicht allzu weit aus dem Fenster. Wir haben jetzt schon recht viel besprochen, aber ich möchte doch noch ganz kurz mit dir über Thomas Hengen sprechen, weil du hast ihn vorhin kurz angesprochen. Der sportliche Geschäftsführer war ja früher mal Kapitän, dann bei Aachen als Sportdirektor im Einsatz und hat auch schon als Scout und Kaderplaner gearbeitet, für Everton, für den HSV, für West Ham United und PSV Eindhoven. Und ehrlich gesagt, all diese letzten Dinge, die waren mir überhaupt nicht mehr geläufig. Also das musste ich mir alles erst wieder erarbeiten. Welche Rolle spielt er beim jetzigen Erfolg und was ist er für ein Typ?
Also man kann glaube ich ganz klar sagen, dass Thomas Hengen ein absoluter Glücksgriff ist für den ersten FC Kaiserslautern. Er wird auch ganz gerne von den Fans, gerade auch bei Twitter in der sogenannten Betze Timeline, sehr, sehr gefeiert für seine Transfers, die er jetzt auch wieder getätigt hat, wird da gerne auch mal als Don Hengen bezeichnet, weil es ihm ja tatsächlich auch gelungen ist, den ein oder anderen, ich will nicht sagen Kracher zu verpflichten, aber ich meine, also sind wir mal ehrlich, dass ein Andi Lute auf den Betzenberg gekommen ist, damit hätten glaube ich die wenigsten gerechnet. Natürlich ist er schon in seinem Fußballer Herbst, aber dass der noch mal den Schritt zum FCK geht, okay, Eric Durm genauso, also der hat schon den ein oder anderen Transfer an Land gezogen, wo man sagen muss, Respekt, klar, da sind im Hintergrund, die eben schon angesprochenen Investoren, die da auch Geld geben und solche Dinge dann ermöglichen, aber ich glaube genau das, was du auch angesprochen hast, was dir nicht mehr so geläufig war, diese Arbeit von Thomas Heng, bevor er beim FCK war, als Scout und auch international tätig, in England tätig, ich glaube, das kommt ihm jetzt auch zu Gute. Ich glaube, dass er einfach in der Zeit ein sehr, sehr gutes Netzwerk aufgebaut hat. Ich glaube, dass er in der Zeit einfach sehr, sehr viel gelernt hat, dass er so ein bisschen weg vom Radar in Deutschland war, auch dann in Aachen. Das war ja jetzt nichts, bei allem Respekt vor allem an Aachen, aber das war jetzt nichts, was in der breiten Öffentlichkeit besonders stark beobachtet wurde. Aber ich glaube, dass er davon jetzt eben zehrt, dass er jetzt eben seine Qualitäten ausspielen kann. Und was er geschafft hat, ist, er hat eine unglaubliche Ruhe auch reingebracht in dieses zuvor sehr, sehr unruhige Umfeld. Also was für uns Journalisten ziemlich kacke ist, aber für den Verein gut ist das, was Thomas Hengen gemacht hat. Es kommt so gut wie nichts mehr nach draußen, auch was Transfergerüchte angeht. Also man hat Dinge erst sehr, sehr spät kurz vor Abschluss mitbekommen und generell dringt sehr, sehr wenig aus dem innersten Kreis des 1. FCKs das Lautern mittlerweile nach draußen. Und das ist, was der FCK bitter nötig gehabt hat, weil es da sehr, sehr viele schmutzige Grabenkämpfe gab in den letzten Jahren. Und das hat Thomas Hengen geschafft. Und man muss ja –ich weiß, wir sind schon lange drauf, was das Thema angeht. Das muss ich aber auch noch sagen. Man muss ja auch sagen, Thomas Hengen ist ja mittlerweile quasi alleiniger Boss beim FCK. Also er hat ja eigentlich mal noch einen kaufmännischen Kollegen an der Seite gehabt und macht das ja mittlerweile alleine und ist quasi nicht nur Sportchef, sondern komplett FCK-Chef. Von daher, ja, Hut ab, wie er das alles meistert. Und er hat den Laden echt im Griff, muss man sagen.
Absolut, also beim FCK läuft es gerade sehr, sehr gut und es dringt wenig nach außen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich jetzt die Überleitung zum HSV und Fortuna Düsseldorf bauen soll, deswegen gehe ich einfach nicht den einfachen Weg und sage, das ist das letzte Spiel, über das wir noch sprechen wollen. Der HSV, der als Tabellenführer diesen Spieltag beschließen darf, unter anderem, weil man gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf zu Hause mit 2 zu 0 gewinnt. Die Tore machen Jatta in der Nachspielzeit und Robert Glatzl in der 21. Minute. Und damit steht der HSV, Tobi, nicht nur bei 21 Punkten nach 9 Spielen, hat siebenmal gewonnen, zweimal verloren, sondern man hat auch die wirklich beeindruckende Torbilanz von 14 zu 5 Toren. Also man ist unglaublich defensiv stark da in Hamburg.
Ja, und das war mein Live-Spiel dieses Wochenende. Ich war vor Ort im Stadion, habe es mir angeguckt. Und ich muss sagen, auch im Hinblick darauf, dass der nächste Gegner vom HSV, Hannover 96, ist, ich war schon ein bisschen, das hat mich so ein bisschen angespannt, die ganze Geschichte. Die haben das schon echt gut gemacht, die Hamburger. Das hat Spaß gemacht, denen zuzugucken. Die müssen eigentlich schon 2-0 führen, bevor sie überhaupt das 1-0 machen. Hatten da Chancen, das Ding an die Latte geknallt und all solche Geschichten. Und spielen einfach einen richtig, richtig schönen Ball. Also dieses 1 zu 0, ich glaube, Vuskovic war es, der so einen Außenristpass als Eröffnung nach außen spielt, wo Jatta dann steht, abgeht, den Ball reinflankt und da steht dann Glatzel und macht den komplett humorlos rein. Das hat mich schon sehr, sehr beeindruckt. Und ich glaube, dass das mit den wenigen Gegentoren, zumindest gegen Düsseldorf, auch ein gutes Stück an Düsseldorf lag. Denn nach dem 2 zu 0 ist das Spiel dann insgesamt so in der zweiten, nicht nach dem zweiten, nach der Halbzeit. Nach der Halbzeit ist das Spiel dann insgesamt so ein bisschen verflacht, hatte ich das Gefühl. Man hat sich eher Richtung Düsseldorf orientiert, Düsseldorf nicht Richtung Hamburg, was die Leistung angeht. Und so sah die zweite Halbzeit dann auch aus. Also Hamburg hat das irgendwie so weggespielt. Also die waren schon besser und auch dominant, aber jetzt nicht mehr so wirklich zwingend. Und haben vielleicht auch ein bisschen versäumt, den Sack ein Stückchen früher zuzumachen. Das war ja dann erst die 90. als Jatta das Tor gemacht hat. Aber ich glaube, dass sie keine Tore gegen Düsseldorf gekriegt haben, war an dem Tag auch viel Düsseldorfs Unvermögen. Weil die haben mich im Gegensatz zur restlichen Saison am Samstagabend nicht überzeugt.
Am Ende nur drei Schüsse für Düsseldorf, kein einziger Aufs-Tor. Das ist dann doch schon sehr, sehr deutlich in der Torschuss-Statistik. Also den Schuss ein Aufs-Tor. Da hat Hamburg ein 8 zu 0. Und da ist dann so das Endergebnis von 2 zu 0 auch nicht mehr so ganz überraschend. Sebastian, kannst du erklären, was da los war mit der Fortuna?
Nee, ich kann es dir nicht beantworten, Max. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, woran das bei der Fortuna liegt. Hab aber auch ehrlicherweise zu wenig von der Fortuna bislang gesehen in der Saison. Vielleicht war es einfach die Angst vom großen HSV, der ihn da Angst eingejagt hat, weil er ja zum Aufstieg verdammt ist, sozusagen. Aber nee, ich glaube, da war einfach nach vorne viel zu wenig von der Fortuna zu sehen, in dem Spiel bis auf den Abseits-Tor, was aber auch klar abseits war. Und ja, der HSV auf der anderen Seite hat halt individuelle Klasse, das hat man gesehen. Gerade auch bei dem 1 zu 0, da ist die Vorarbeit eigentlich schöner als das Tor an sich. Auch was der Jatta da macht, wie der den Ball mitnimmt und dann vorlegt für Glatzel, das ist echt erste Sahne. Und dann hast du halt auch nochmal Qualität, die von der Bank reinkommt, mit Kittel, der halt wirklich auch nochmal echt Alarm gemacht hat und auch sehr schön vorgelegt hat, das 2 zu 0 für Jatta. Von daher, ja, ich glaube der HSV steht nicht unverdient da, wo er steht.
Ich finde die Fortuna gar nicht so schlecht. Also, das war, wie gesagt, Samstag, das war eher nix. Das hat mich jetzt nicht so beeindruckt. Und vielleicht können wir es tatsächlich auf den HSV und die stabile Defensive schieben, dass sie gar nicht so viel zugelassen haben an dem Tag. Aber Düsseldorf spielt keine schlechte Saison. Also, man darf nicht vergessen, wenn die das Spiel gewinnen, sind die einen Punkt an den HSV ran. Das würde nicht das Spiel widerspiegeln, aber jetzt sind es natürlich sieben Punkte Rückstand. Deshalb sieht das alles ein bisschen größer aus, was die Lücke angeht. Aber insgesamt spielt Düsseldorf keine schlechte Saison. Also, sie haben so ein bisschen so eine komische Phase gehabt. Da haben sie in Sandhausen verloren, 1-0, 2-2 zu Hause gegen Fürth, die da noch sieglos und so weiter waren, und 2-2 gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Für die galt das Gleiche. Das war so der Moment, wo sie nicht so ganz genau wussten, glaube ich, wo es hingeht. Aber drum herum ist das okay. Also, man kann in Heidenheim verlieren, man kann in Hamburg verlieren. Das passiert ganz anderen Mannschaften und ist völlig in Ordnung. Aber sie gewinnen halt gegen Regensburg. Sie haben den Auftakt gut gestaltet mit einem Sieg in Magdeburg und haben auch Paderborn zu Hause 2 zu 1 geschlagen. Und Paderborn, damit die einzige Niederlage der Saison –nein, das stimmt nicht, eine von zwei Niederlagen der Saison beigefügt –also ich finde, wir sollten nicht zu schlecht über Düsseldorf reden, nur weil das jetzt in Hamburg nicht gut war. Und das wird, wie gesagt, noch ganz, ganz anderen Vereinen ebenfalls so gehen.
Ich glaube, das bindet es wunderbar ab. Und ich glaube, das bindet auch diesen kompletten Spieltag und diese Spieltagsbesprechung ab. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht, mit euch nicht nur auf diesen Spieltag zu blicken, sondern auch noch ein bisschen genauer auf Hannover 96 und den 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Ich danke ganz herzlich Sebastian Zobel vom SWR und dem Nur der FCK Podcast, den ich sehr empfehlen kann, at twitch.redo mit drei O's auf Twitter. Danke dir, lieber Sebastian, dass du wieder mal hier im Rasenfunk warst.
Danke dir, Max. Vielen, vielen Dank und auch vielen, vielen Dank an Tobi.
Ja, da schließe ich mich an. Auch ich möchte Tobi danken. Tobi Rieger, der at runner Tobi, auf Twitter. Ihr kennt ihn natürlich aus der MeinSportPodcast-WG. Danke dir, Tobi, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst. Und wie schön das war, dass wir einfach mal über Sport reden konnten.
Danke für die Einladung, Max. Auch danke an Hannover 96 und auch an die 2. Liga, dass es so ein attraktiver Spieltag war mit 31 Toren. Das hat wirklich was hergemacht. Wir hatten, glaube ich, keine Probleme, Punkte zu finden, die irgendwie interessant waren. Und natürlich auch vielen Dank und beste Grüße an Sebastian.
Ach, ist das hier harmonisch. Das ist ja nicht zum aushalten. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, gebt uns doch mal Feedback, wie ihr jetzt dieses Format mit der Spielbesprechung fandet, im Abgrenzung zu zuletzt, wo wir immer über Vereine gesprochen haben, aber dann eben auch nicht alle erwähnt wurden. Unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder in den sozialen Netzwerken könnt ihr uns Feedback geben und hört auch die anderen Kurzpässe, unter anderem zum ersten Spieltag in der Frauen-Bundesliga und wenn ihr wollt, noch die Schlusskonferenz zum siebten Spieltag in der Männer-Bundesliga. Mein Gott, es gibt viel zu hören! Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk.